[Musique]
depuis 5h30 avec le stress du ces de
tous les préparatifs de pas de faire en
sorte de rien oublié voilà tu dors le
ton sport tant qu'on s'adapte et tu dois
donc pas grand pas longtemps quoi donc
voila comme mais comme on dit c'est de
la bonne pression
[Musique]
j'ai eu une opportunité de quitter la
réunion par le biais d'une histoire
d'amour
d'ailleurs je leur fais un petit big up
à sylvie guillem et lit parce que
aujourd'hui si j'en suis à là c'est un
peu grâce à eux
pour résumer la chose c'est que ça se
passait pas très bien sur le plan
scolaire j'étais un peu rebelle un peu
l'adolescence critique
je suis arrivé à vannes dans le morbihan
en bretagne
très belle région j'ai eu mon bac alors
comme donné perdant je quittais la
réunion avec avertissement au travail
pour te dire je vais redoubler ma
première s j'ai passé peut-être plus
belles années de ma makala de policiers
là-bas j'ai enchaîné directement avec
l'école de police même pas un an après
et j'ai été gardien ap je me suis
toujours ça fait 16 ans aujourd'hui
alléno l'asvel à notre premier pour
micro événement donc on va voir on va
commencer à partir
olivier latyk y aura beaucoup de monde
on va lui faire confiance
[Musique]
il ya un cadre de vie ici qui est tu
trouve pas ailleurs en métropole et à
et surtout il ya un potentiel énorme par
rapport la cuisine réunionnaise parce
qu'il ya voilà il ya celui qui m'a
permis de lancer sa série cuisinier
comment il est
[Musique]
par le biais de cette rencontre ça
m'affecter été la même si 10 ans taux
faut que tu te lances et d'où est née au
tollé là et voilà je me suis lancé avec
zéro vraiment rien du tout vous voulez
là sa qualité notre dada acharnement non
c'est pas de la mangue qui vient la
réunion non seulement c'est difficile
d'en avoir ici on fait ce qu'on peut
mais on le fait bien même qui cadre bien
j ça lui ressemble
c'est quelque chose qui est important
pour lui est qu'il fait partager parce
que ces deux produits sont super beau
ces produits sont à bout blanc sur le
goût de la région c'est le goût du
partage donc
donc c
c'est quelqu'un qui devient très
important pour nous parce que nous
transmettent tous ses malheurs c'est
vrai que nous dans la famille on aime
très bien cuisiner et bombay après il
devenir métropole donc il a fallu il
fallait bien ici anticipate à cuisiner
et
donc il m'appelait de temps en temps
maman comment tu fais ça comment que tu
fais tu es car il donc chaque fois
c'était le petit coup de téléphone voilà
qu est-ce qui comment tu fais ça comment
tu fais ça arrive
voilà on a été séparée depuis 17 ans je
voyais bien qu'une fois par an et
aujourd'hui elle m'a rejoint dans cette
aventure là et du coup s est carrément
au pris au jeu et elle m'aide dans ma
cuisine elle me donne des conseils qui
sont vraiment les meilleurs ça me permet
d'avancer ça a permis de donner un
meilleur goût à ma cuisine une meilleure
qualité et surtout on a réussi à
retrouver des liens très très fort et ça
ça n'a pas pris et c'est ça qui est top
j'ai toute ma famille qui est derrière
moi ce que j'ai aujourd'hui
soit ça montre ce que j'ai aujourd'hui
c'est ça vient pas comme ça c'est une
génétique c'est ma grand mère c'est mes
tantes c'est ma mère c'est voilà c'est
mes amis qui m'ont l'idée c'est mes
cousins cousines qui met tous les jours
à rapatrier des produits locaux pour
faire que notre cuisine et aujourd'hui
elle est ce qu'elle est c'est inquiétant
agressé c'est plutôt parce que quand on
est en pleine préparation quand on est
sur les marchés et il explose de joie
même en faisant les ça vous savez la
musique à fond il est super heureux en
ce moment il est dans une phase un
dynamisme c'est c'est incroyable
dimanche il y avait une dame c'était la
première vient elle se marie amélie là
c'est son métier
j'ai pas te pas du tout mais a dit il
est heureux de faire ça je dis oui il
est complètement heureux là il épanouie
on le fait parce qu'on aime le faire si
tu veux si tu fais quelque chose par par
force aux autres ça vaut pas le coup
voilà ma volonté qui était de rentrer au
pays
aujourd'hui c'est pas évident avec tout
un contexte familial qui est bien
particulier j'ai réussi à faire un pont
comme dit olivier car d'abba casse avec
son vin voilà j'ai réussi à faire un
pont
entre la réunion et bordeaux et du coup
là je suis complètement épanoui quoi
nous sommes capables de pouvoir
travailler partout dans le monde nous
sommes capables de pouvoir être des
entrepreneurs être des commerçants être
même dès des ouvriers peu importe quel
que soit le métier que l'on veut
exploiter tant dans notre chance partout
dans le monde et nous avons ici plus
qu'ailleurs de bonnes raisons de faire
en sorte que d'être bien dans ce pays
parce que ceux ci le nôtre est de
pouvoir encore une fois compter sur nous
et compter sur une capacité qui est
vraiment réel la métropole c'est très
très très formateur moi personnellement
oui j'ai un titre et tout le monde a à
prendre le large à pourquoi c'est ça qui
est important c'est de savoir pourquoi
prendre le large et quitté la réunion
parce que moi j'ai quitté la réunion à
18 ans tout pile et j'étais rebelle jeu
crasher un peu sur la ligne quand tu
vois et ça fait 17 ans que j'ai en
métropole ben je peux vous assurer que
le plus bel endroit pour moi que où il
fait bon vivre ça à la réunion ça y'a
pas photo aujourd'hui je vois ma culture
je l ai en moi elle est imprégnée
je pense qu'on a on a un lingot d'or qui
s'appelle la réunion on a un savoir
faire là bas si on arrive à ne pas faire
il ya croyais avoir gagné
[Musique]